(haunting music)
- [Sarah] When I go down the slope,
it takes me three seconds to get
from zero to 60 miles an hour.
(dramatic music)
(skis whooshing)
I honestly can't explain
what it feels like,
even after 15 years of doing the sport.
My name is Sarah Hendrickson,
and I'm an Olympic ski jumper.
Ski jumping is a sport where
I go down a two-track slope
at 55 miles an hour and,
when the slope ends,
I jump, flying about a football
field in length in the air.
(dramatic music)
When I'm getting ready to go,
the smell is of the fresh air
from the trees and the snow in the area
and the feeling of cold,
brisk air on my face.
When I put my goggles on,
I know it's time to go.
(dramatic music)
My eyesight, when I'm
going down the slope,
is right in front of the tips of my skis.
My skis are bouncing up
and down in the track
against the ice, it feels like clatter.
If you hear it, it's like a rumble.
The flight takes three seconds,
but honestly time slows
down and it feels like
an eternity where I get to enjoy flying.
As I'm flying, I can't hear anything.
It's completely silent all around.
The wind on my body feels
like when you put your hand
out of a car window
going 60 miles an hour.
Moving it up and down, you
can feel the lift and drag
it has on your hand.
That's like ski jumping
but for your whole body.
As I'm flying, I'm totally alone.
I'm in control of all my
senses and all my movements.
It's the best feeling in the world.
(dramatic music)
(electronic tones chiming)